Trascrizione: ilaris ujka
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Ma insomma, che cos’è la musica?
La musica è la chiave!
Che ne siate consci o meno,
siamo tutti esseri musicali,
che vivono in un universo musicale.
Tutto è musica.
(Suoni di percussioni)
Tutto suona, anche i gesti quotidiani.
(Suono di passi)
Camminare.
Nuoto.
(Suono di bracciate a nuoto)
Musica.
Sport.
(Suono di palla da tennis)
Senti!
Musica!
Anche bere un caffè è musica,
perché i movimenti necessari
per compiere questo gesto
sono concatenati in una certa sequenza
e in un certo tempo, come per suonare.
Per non parlare del mondo esterno:
uccellini, foglie, vento, voci, auto.
Ma c'è di più!
Questo accade a livello superficiale,
la musica invece è anche
all'interno della materia,
delle cellule, degli atomi.
Tutto quello che appartiene
al mondo fisico, materiale,
ma anche spirituale ed emotivo,
nasce da un nucleo sonoro,
da una struttura
intrinsecamente vibratoria.
Secondo la scienza moderna attuale
è ormai assodato che esiste
un campo di vibrazione dinamica
che unisce e sostiene,
sopra il quale fluttua l'intera esistenza.
Quindi, l'universo è musica solidificata
ed è in questo mare di frequenze
che noi tutti galleggiamo.
Ma allora, se il nostro corpo
viene dalla musica,
viviamo in un mondo musicale,
in un universo musicale,
che ruolo deve avere
la musica nelle nostre vite?
Terapeutico, preventivo,
spirituale, curativo
oppure matematico, fisico,
ricreativo, di aggregazione?
Tutti, tutti!
Noi oggi però prenderemo in esame
solo un aspetto, quello educativo,
e il perché lo capiremo
prendendo in prestito
due frasi di Platone.
La prima frase è:
"Il più importante,
e principale affare pubblico,
è la buona educazione della gioventù."
Perché lo capiate meglio:
la cosa più importante che devono fare
delle persone quando stanno insieme,
che sia una famiglia o una nazione,
è pensare a crescere bene i propri figli,
non aggiungo altro.
La seconda frase è:
"Lasciateci descrivere l'educazione
dei nostri uomini.
Come deve essere quindi l'educazione?
Forse difficilmente potremmo
trovare qualcosa di meglio
di quanto ha già scoperto
l'esperienza del passato
la quale consiste, io credo,
nella ginnastica per il corpo
e nella musica per la mente.
Platone, che è esistito tra il quinto
e il quarto secolo avanti Cristo,
dice che già in passato
avevano scoperto questa cosa,
che la musica e la ginnastica
erano fondamentali per i nostri figli,
per la crescita dei bambini.
In ogni epoca storica, ogni pedagogista,
da Rousseau a Socrate, Quintiliano,
Steiner, Piaget, Montessori:
tutti quanti convergono nella stessa idea,
cioè che sia di fondamentale importanza
dare un'educazione musicale ai bambini
e che non esistono bambini dotati o meno.
L'educazione musicale è importante,
perché altrimenti cresceremo
degli individui privi di sensibilità
non solo nei confronti della musica,
ma in tutto ciò che è
espressione e comunicazione.
Non serve scomodare
questi personaggi illustri
per capire una cosa fondamentale,
questa!
Siamo stati tutti nove mesi, più o meno,
nella pancia della mamma.
Notte, giorno, caldo,
freddo, pioggia, sole,
per nove mesi abbiamo sentito
un battito incessante
che ha accompagnato la nostra crescita
e assieme ad esso una melodia eterea
ed avvolgente, come il respiro.
Per nove mesi noi abbiamo sentito questo.
(Respiri e battito cardiaco)
Se poi la mamma era in ritardo
e con la spesa -
(Respiro affannato e battito accelerato)
È chiaro che poi,
quando siamo venuti al mondo,
eravamo dei musicisti esperti,
la prima cosa che abbiamo fatto
è emettere un suono.
A ogni sollecitazione sonora,
un bambino interagisce
immediatamente e con gioia.
La scena è questa: Giacomino ha un anno -
(Musica)
e Giacomino che ha un anno
con il pannolone comincia subito
a interpretare a modo suo
con questo suo pannolone.
Tutti quanti intorno a lui, la famiglia:
"Bravo Giacomino, bravo Giacomo!".
E Giacomino contento balla, fino a che
non raggiunge i cinque - sei anni
e poi si accorge che a ballare
è solo lui, normalmente.
Quindi sono la cultura
e il sistema scolastico
che plasmano o insabbiano
questa musicofilia.
Vediamo un attimo a livello scolastico,
come è messo il nostro sistema educativo.
Adesso faccio un po’ il pagliaccio,
però non ci vado distante.
"Fra Martino campanaro",
"Tu scendi dalle stelle".
Con bambini pietrificati dalla paura,
maestre isteriche che suggeriscono,
genitori annoiati che riprendono
uno spettacolo che non è
proprio così allegro.
Negli asili nido, in 20 anni
ne ho girati centinaia,
in tutti si ascoltano le stesse canzoni:
"le polpette di nonna Pina",
"il coccodrillo fa così",
come se i bambini, con la loro magia,
non riuscissero a percepire
Ravi Shankar o Beethoven.
Alle medie, flauto dolce.
Ma secondo voi,
con i ritmi forsennati
della nostra società,
un flauto dolce può far innamorare
un bambino della musica?
Io dico: prendi una batteria,
montala al completo e digli "Vai!".
(Suoni e gesti di percussioni)
E vedrai se non gli piace!
Prendi un amplificatore da 100 watt,
attaccaci un jack e una chitarra elettrica
e digli: "Vai bambino, vai! ".
E lui -
(Suono di chitarra elettrica)
A lui è chiaro che piace!
Bisogna far innamorare
i bambini della musica
e capire
che la musica non è importante
solo o tanto quanto la matematica,
la storia e la geografia,
ma di più.
Musica e ginnastica sono le basi.
È per questo che negli ultimi 20 anni
mi sono dedicato a un progetto
di pedagogia musicale,
che ha come obiettivo quello di arrivare
a bambini in stato di disagio.
Il disagio può essere di due tipi:
un disagio materiale -
mancanza di "sghèi" -
o un disagio emotivo - PlayStation-.
Dopo, questo progetto l'ho applicato
in Veneto per 20 anni:
circa 80 istituti ne hanno preso parte,
20.000 bambini hanno preso
parte a questo progetto
e dopo questa esperienza nella regione
ho deciso di darle
una veste internazionale.
Così sono stato a Calcutta, in India,
in Togo, in Africa Occidentale
e nella Repubblica Domenicana.
Il mio obiettivo non è quello
di formare percussionisti,
il mio obiettivo è quello
di piantare un seme,
anzi di riscoprire un tesoro
che è lì da sempre.
Per me non è importante
che il bambino suoni la chitarra,
il flauto, il violino
o faccia il calzolaio,
piuttosto che il medico.
Per me, è importante che il bambino
capisca il valore della musica,
l'importanza della musica
e la sua valenza universale.
Questo progetto, che sto portando in giro
a livello internazionale,
ha un percorso che dura
due mesi e mezzo o tre
e che sfocia con uno spettacolo finale.
In questo spettacolo finale
tutti i bambini,
fino a 250 in Togo in Africa,
suonano tamburi fatti da loro
con materiale riciclato,
e decorati da loro.
Dopodiché inizia la fase
della continuità, quando io torno qui:
prima di andarmene,
formo dei gruppi di bambini
in base alla predisposizione individuale,
compro gli strumenti,
inserisco degli insegnanti locali
e pago loro delle mensilità
affinché si installino
dei corsi stabili di musica.
Perché questo?
Perché la musica cambia gli stati d'animo,
cambia le persone, cambia una casa,
cambia un quartiere, cambia il mondo.
La musica rende liberi,
come ha detto il mio filosofo preferito,
che è Bob Marley.
Ho visto nel corso degli anni
il più grande percussionista brasiliano,
Carlinhos Brown,
costruire nella favela in cui è nato
una scuola di musica, Pracatum:
ora questa favela, da luogo di degrado,
è diventata luogo di turismo,
di arte e di cultura.
Ho visto a Bishkek
un bambino di cinque anni,
che ha preso parte
al progetto proposto in India,
iniziare a parlare tramite la musica.
Non l'aveva mai fatto prima.
Ho visto ragazzi disabili,
feriti nel corpo e nell'anima
da un incidente stradale,
trovare la voglia di esprimersi
tramite i tamburi e la voglia di vivere.
Ho visto ragazzi
a Salvador de Bahia
destinati ai cartelli della droga
venire formati in scuole di musica
per bambini di strada,
uscire a diciott'anni
come musicisti professionisti
e tornare nella stessa scuola
come insegnanti.
Ho visto decine di bambini
e di ragazzi ormai adulti,
incontrarmi per strada e salutarmi,
ringraziandomi del percorso
svolto 25 anni fa,
di cui conservano un ricordo vivo
e da cui sono partiti
per entrare nel mondo della musica.
Conclusione: come vi lascio?
Cosa vi portate a casa
da tutta questa cosa?
Una cosa fondamentale:
ballate, cantate, suonate,
ascoltate più che potete!
Ogni giorno!
Perché quando fate
queste azioni siete felici.
Cosa stiamo cercando dalla vita,
se non la felicità?
Non aspettate quella volta al mese,
quella volta all'anno,
per ballare e cantare
perché vi sentite felici.
Fate il contrario:
ballate, cantate e suonate
per trovare la felicità.
Vivete la musica ognuno a modo vostro,
perché la musica è importante
anche in una sala operatoria,
nella costruzione di un ponte,
nell’allattare un bambino
o nel crescere una pianta.
Che voi la cerchiate o meno,
che vi sentiate particolarmente
musicali o meno,
la musica esercita, sulla totalità
di noi, un enorme potere.
Questa musicofilia è lampante
fin dalla nascita
e risale agli albori della nostra specie:
può essere plasmata dalla vita,
dagli eventi, dal talento,
ma è radicata in noi, è innata.
Siamo tutti creature musicali
e quindi è fondamentale abbandonarsi
a questo meraviglioso codice
che è la musica.